they say raising kids is a job in itself
rising bills the summer holidays it's an
expensive time for families
especially when you're a single parent
for lucy benefits are a lifeline
but they aren't enough
she's just about breaking even we're not
gonna be able to survive i think
something's gonna give
whether that's me not paying my
electricity bills or me not paying my
rent i am losing sleep over that to be
fair
concerns like this are only growing
it's influenced some mps to demand
breathing space for those receiving help
a review and increase of the benefits
cap in line with current inflation and a
temporary halt on their deductions to
help people make ends meet
benefits are already at a very low level
in real terms it's the lowest level for
over 30 years if on top of that you've
got money being taken away by the
government before your benefit payments
are made and we're talking about
typically around about 60 pounds a month
that is extraordinarily hard
take sue for example
after various benefit deductions this
month she'll be left with 61 pounds
universal credit
my age i've never known it to be as
disheartening as what it is there's no
light forward you don't even you know
all the bickering that they're doing
to see who's going to be the next prime
minister
what what is that doing for everybody
that's sitting there
trying to put food on the table
no i'm going to be the one hungry
cheap lunches for now will have to do
sabha chowdhury sky news hertfordshire